[Musique]
sous les pieds de ses archéologues
afghans les traces d'un riche passé
oublié accroché à plus de 2400 mètres
d'altitude au milieu des steppes
désertiques de l'est de l'afghanistan
à chaque coup de pioche à chaque coup de
pinceau des vestiges sortent de terre
les plus anciens repose là depuis près
de 1800 ans
[Musique]
tous date de l'époque où chan du nom
d'un peuple bouddhiste venus d'inde au
3e siècle avant même la naissance de
l'islam
au milieu de ces trésors béret vissé sur
la tête philippe marquis c'est le chef
de la dafa la délégation archéologique
française en afghanistan
présente depuis des dizaines d'années
dans le pays
[Musique]
quand il ya quand même un travail de
précision que les mecs on faire
piètre qualité avec son équipe il
apporte son aide aux afghans sur ce
chantier qualifié d'exceptionnel
exceptionnel parce que il n'y a plus
beaucoup de sites comme ça qu'ils
existent en afghanistan exceptionnel
parce que déjà je pense à l'époque
c'était ainsi tout à fait remarquable
par son ampleur par la qualité de ses
décorations et on est vraiment dans
quelque chose qui est qui vraiment hors
normes à ce point de vue là pourtant ce
site est condamnée à très court terme et
la sentence est sans appel à quelques
centaines de mètres une société chinoise
s'est déjà installé dans ces bâtiments
au toit bleu
et elle n'est pas venu là pour faire de
l'archéologie si derrière ce qui est
ce qui est en quelque sorte le coeur du
problème et cette montagne elle est
super plaisir bourré de cuivre donc il
ya des filons clients qui sont en fait
aux sons godeau pratiquement verticaux à
cet endroit et qui ont été exploitées
pendant l'antiquité et qui vont donc
être exploité dans les années qui
viennent
l'extraction du précieux minerai se fera
à coup de puissants explosifs
des déflagrations qui pulvériseront
aussi les vestiges archéologiques
installé à quelques dizaines de mètres
il ne reste que quelques mois voire
quelques semaines avant le début des
opérations
vous
[Musique]
le chantier se trouve à une heure de
route plein sud depuis kaboul
les fouilles ont démarré il ya un an
elle occupe aujourd'hui une soixantaine
d'archéologues arguant nader rasouli
dirige tout ce petit monde
c'est lui le responsable des recherches
nader a appris le français au lycée de
kaboul et il en est très fière sa selle
3e 4e siècle les 4 août
les objets que doit la trouver à chaque
découverte
c'est un petit morceau de l'histoire de
son pays qui ressurgit maintenant vous
pouvez voir soul qu'il ya plein de
statues d'argile ici dans cette foule
quand on a trouvé l'obligent à coucher
vous pouvez voir avec la couleur rouge
est aussi une brouille stature que le
pied sous les yourtes a pour elle une
lettre à 40 cm le corps peut être sept
m le reste de la statue a disparu mais
la découverte et de premier ordre le
doigt
ça c'est très important pour notre et
aussi pour les cultures simple c'est
juste un bouddha couché à la place ça va
mieux pour notre histoire et pour les
touristes et pour les autres
mais malheureusement à cause de
l'explosion
ce que kampala
nader a compris qu'il ne pourrait pas
tous sauvés alors il pare au plus pressé
les afghans tentent d'extraire un
maximum de statut les français eux ont
une autre mission le moindre objet la
moindre pierre et le moindre monument
doivent être recensées ce qu'on est en
train de faire surtout si on est en
train d'essayer de documenter tous et
documenté c'est à dire car des dessins
faire des plans on fait tout récolter le
maximum d'informations sur ces
constructions avant fin que tout ça soit
potentiellement détruire ce qui le peut
devrait être démontée et déplacé si
possible vers le musée de kaboul
le site est gigantesque au milieu ici un
monastère avec des cellules pour les
moines et des dizaines d'autres petites
pièces et tout autour c'est stupa en
pierre sorte de chapelle construite à la
mémoire du bouddha les plus grands de
ses stupa sont probablement condamné
mais nicolas a bon espoir de sauver les
petits comme celui ci il en fait le plan
millimétré avant de le démonter
sont là c'est beau parce qu'ils sont
construits en toutes petites lames de
pierre pincemaille à ses fins ils sont
relativement bon état assez important et
l'association un peu partout notamment
dans les chapelles du monastère avec
d'une riche très riche sculptures de
terre crue montre qu'ici c'est un site
exceptionnel pour l'histoire du
bouddhisme en afghanistan les
archéologues ne travaille aujourd'hui
que sur la partie visible de l'iceberg
tout autour des murailles d'autres stupa
d'autres monastères une cité entière est
encore enfouis sous terre
une richesse inouïe qui ne va pourtant
pas empêcher l'exploitation de la mine
l'enjeu est énorme
des scientifiques ont repéré ici le
deuxième plus important gisement de
cuivre de la planète
une société chinoise n'a pas hésité elle
a déboursé 8 milliards de dollars pour
obtenir la concession de la mine c'est
le plus gros investissement jamais
réalisé dans l'histoire du pays
depuis ce camp retranché à pousser en
quelques mois une trentaine de hangar au
moins capable d'héberger des centaines
d'ouvriers mais les chinois se font très
discrets
nous n'avons jamais pu nous approcher de
leur camp on y rencontrer un responsable
il y à un mur d'enceinte des miradors et
mille cinq cents policiers afghans qui
surveillent le site jour et nuit samedi
sur la route des checkpoints tous les
300 mètres
vous avez des armes mais nous n'avons
pas d'armes
ils ont une caméra h f
donnez moi votre caméra non non on va
pas vous la donner interdiction de
filmer ce qui se passe ici est
soigneusement cachée aux visiteurs trop
curieux un journaliste afghan a tout de
même réussi à pénétrer sur leur site
c'était il ya six mois il avait reçu
l'autorisation exceptionnelle de filmer
le début des travaux aux quatre coins au
loin il ya des postes de sécurité pour
sauver la mise
là ce sont les hangars où vivent les
ouvriers et ici vous pouvez les voir ils
font déjà les premiers tests pour
préparer le terrain de la mine il y à
des ouvriers afghans qui travaillent
avec eux ils travaillent sous le
contrôle des chinois ils ne sont pas
formés
ce ne sont ni des techniciens ni des
professionnels et ils ont un salaire
très ferme
seddik ahmadzaï travail pour une
émission d'investigation sur cham chape
tv une chaîne privée totalement
indépendante du gouvernement
dès le début de son enquête il a été
surpris les chinois semblent faire tout
ce qu'ils veulent sans contrôle des
autorités afghanes
il a poursuivi ses recherches et
rapidement des soupçons de corruption à
très grande échelle ont vu le jour
si on évoque le sujet de la corruption
eh bien peut-être que la fraude a touché
l'ensemble de notre gouvernement et même
au delà
ils disent qu'il y avait seize ou
dix-sept pays candidats pour exploiter
la mine alors pourquoi est ce que c'est
la chine qui emportait ce contrat
pourquoi ce n'est pas les états unis le
canada ou le kazakhstan au coeur du
scandale il ya cet homme le ministre des
mines il aurait touché 2 grosse somme de
la part des chinois 30 millions de
dollars selon des journalistes américain
du washington post
j'ai posé cette question au ministre il
m'a répondu en se moquant que 3 millions
ça aurait pu être possible mais que 30
millions aucun ministre monde n'a jamais
touché autant d'argent
ibrahim adel a depuis été démis de ses
fonctions il vivrait aujourd'hui à dubaï
seddik ahmadzaï vie lui la peur au
ventre après avoir été menacé tout comme
sa famille mais mes supérieurs mais
rédacteur en chef ont reçu des menaces
qu'on nous a demandé de ne plus jamais
diffuser de telles émissions
et
pendant six semaines nous avons tenté
d'obtenir un rendez vous au ministère
des mines pour parler de ce fameux
contrat signé avec la chine sans succès
les journalistes étrangers ne sont pas
les bienvenus
[Musique]
ce n'est vraiment pas possible non je
suis désolé ce n'est pas possible on a
insisté on a contacté les responsables
mais vous savez c'est difficile
à gauche c'est lorenzo délègue il est
français et travaille pour une
organisation financée par la banque
mondiale et les nations unies
son but traquer la corruption jusqu'au
sommet de l'état
pourquoi ils ont leur bac on leur pose
des questions qu'est ce qu'ils ont à
cacher des trucs de corruption des dînes
avec les chinois
je crois qu'ils ont très peur de
communiquer parce qu'il est en partie
aussi de fessenheim à coup sûr
sur ce qui se passe par là qu'on leur
pose des questions qui peuvent s'étendre
voilà depuis deux ans lorenzo travail
ici avec jawad sur les zones d'ombré qui
entourent ce colossal projet minier les
deux hommes se sont procurés une copie
du contrat qui lie l'afghanistan à la
chine sur le papier tout semble correct
donc là on n'est plus du contrat et des
négociations sur des employés quel type
d'employés vont être mis en place à
partir de quelle année etc
c'est apparemment à des meilleurs
contrats miniers qui a été fait dans ces
dernières années au niveau à l'échelle
mondiale le problème c'est que si la
compagnie paye certaines personnes clés
à l'intérieur du gouvernement pour faire
en sorte que les choses s'accélèrent et
ne soit pas fait exactement comme dans
le contrat eh bien ça peut mener à des
gros problèmes écologiques sociaux de
problèmes de revenus à long terme pour
l'état et donc c'est extrêmement
important que ces choses-là se fasse
bien après 30 ans de guerre
les institutions afghanes n'était pas
préparé à gérer un contrat de cette
ampleur
jawad a pu le constater au cours de ses
recherches à proximité de la mine ils
nous emmènent rencontrer les premières
victimes
la population locale les habitants ont
été expulsés de leurs maisons
construites pour leur plus grand malheur
sur les réserves de cuivre
nous essayons de mesurer combien leur
vie vont changer et de voir ce que le
gouvernement devrait faire pour eux ce
que la société civile devraient faire et
comment les leaders de ces communautés
devraient se positionner
est-ce qu'ils comprennent tout ce qui
est en train de se passer
non pas du tout pas du tout
mirwais était le chef d'un village qui
comme 17 autres a été rayé de la carte
afin de libérer la zone pour les chinois
du jour au lendemain les habitants du
plié bagage sans recevoir la moindre
indemnité avant notre vie était belle et
douce nous étions chez nous et même si
parfois nous avions faim au moins nous
étions dans nos maisons
maintenant tout a changé
notre maison est là bas nous nous sommes
ici et ici c'est le désert
il n'y a pas d'école pas de rue pas de
mosquée pas de clinique en plus des
autres membres de ma famille ont dû
partir ailleurs
nous ne sommes plus ensemble certains
ont pu trouver refuge ici en toute hâte
derrière ces murs de terre 50 familles
au total qui manquent de tout il n'y a
pas d'eau pas d'électricité pas même une
route pour se rendre en ville
jawad est venu rencontrer les anciens et
recueillir leurs témoignages
[Musique]
quand nous essayons de nous adresser au
gouvernement
ils nous disent qu'ils vont nous donner
des terres dans un autre endroit
ils nous font des promesses mais on ne
voit jamais rien les chinois vont gagner
plein d'argent et le gouvernement aussi
mais quel sera mon bénéfice
je ne suis vraiment pas content il ne
serons heureux que quand je serai mort
tout ce qu'ils demandent c'est une
petite compensation pour leurs terrains
en fait ils ne se rendent pas compte de
la taille de ce projet c'est tellement
gigantesque 3 milliards
d'investissements ils ne peuvent pas
imaginer
il ne peut pas se rendre compte de tout
ce qui va changer
une vraie petite ville va sortir de
terre ici qu eux ce sont quelques
milliers de personnes qui sont laissés
tristement sur le bord du chemin
à mille lieues des problèmes de ces
villageois
le gouverneur de la province et son
escorte armée jusqu'aux dents avec
l'exploitation de la mine certains ont
tout perdu
lui est désormais à la tête de la région
la plus riche du pays
sa province est toujours en proie à
l'insurrection
les habitants sont épuisés par la guerre
pourtant à en croire son discours bien
rodé
la solution à tous ces mots ce sont
précisément les chinois les chinois nous
on fait des promesses
ils vont construire des hôpitaux et les
écoles les rues seront goudronnée tous
les problèmes des habitants seront
résolus maintenant on attend qu'il fasse
tout ça ils le feront c'est sûr et
certain
et s'ils ne le font pas c'est un crime
il ya quelques jours j'ai eu une réunion
avec les chinois
comme je les ai avertis que s'ils ne
tenaient pas leur promesse leur travail
s'arrêtera immédiatement d'accord écrit
je leur ai déjà dit ça cette mine de
cuivre va apporter de bonnes choses si
dieu le veut
ma province pourra résoudre tous les
problèmes économiques du pays
de réelles convictions ou optimisme de
façade le gouverneur repart toujours en
très bonne compagnie
seule chose certaine aujourd'hui dans
les rues la province il n'y a toujours
rien pas le moindre signe de
développement ou d'amélioration
impossible d'imaginer que la région est
aujourd'hui si riche
[Musique]
pendant ce temps là sur le site des
fouilles
la course contre la montre continue
aujourd'hui pour gagner du temps
anne laure s'est déplacé jusqu'au
chantier chargé de la restauration des
vestiges
elle travaille d'habitude à kaboul mais
de nouvelles statues viennent d'être
mises au jour c'est intéressant parce
qu'en fait il ya clairement une petite
chapelle
en parallèle en fait et ici en fait il
ya deux éléments de bois qui pourraient
être les mêlées montant d'une porte ça
aussi c'est très intéressant parce que
cette chapelle se situe peut-être à
hauteur du regard en fait on ouvrait des
portes et on voyait pas ce que ce qui à
la la mission d'anne laure est délicate
il s'agit de recoller une à une de
minuscules feuille d'or qui recouvrait
autrefois ce bouddha en lévitation
il faut restaurer au maximum les statuts
avant de pouvoir les déplacer
c'est le genre de travail qu'on n'aime
pas trop faire dans l'urgence mais enfin
il n'y a pas vraiment le choix
déjà si on pouvait arriver à sauver
cette petite partie de chapelle pour
pouvoir la présenter au musée ça ce
serait fantastique sauver des bouddhas
en afghanistan le défi a pris un sens
nouveau
depuis ce jour de mars 2001
[Musique]
c'était à 300 kilomètres de là des
statuts de la même époque
sculptée dans la roche par le même
peuple les deux bouddhas monumentaux de
bamiyan l'un de 53 m l'autre de 38 m
parti en poussière dynamité sur ordre du
mollah omar le chef suprême des talibans
qui jugeait ses statuts contraire à
l'islam
[Musique]
ironie du sort ne vont plus tard les
talibans ne sont plus au pouvoir mais
les bouddhas sont toujours menacés autre
époque autre menace hier les fanatiques
aujourd'hui cette mine de cuivre mais
pas seulement
les pillages ont aussi causé de très
grande perte les équipes de nader le
constate tous les jours celle contre bas
qui ont enlevé la tête de cette stature
ils ont arraché tout ça et vous vous
pouvez voir ici les cocottes rebonds en
lever une partie de peinture moral un
morceau de fresques comme celui-là au
marché noir peut se revendre des
milliers de dollars aujourd'hui le site
est surveillée le soir les ouvriers
afghans sont même fouillé avant de
rentrer chez eux
pour être certain qu'il n'emporte rien
pour mesurer l'importance du phénomène
nous nous sommes rendus dans le quartier
commerçant de kaboul avec une caméra
cachée dans un sac
nous nous sommes fait passer pour des
acheteurs d'antiquités au bout de trois
jours des vendeurs nous contacter ils
nous font pénétrer dans leur boutique de
souvenirs la porte est aussitôt
verrouillé sans vouloir chercher des
bouddhas royal des bouddhas ça vient du
logar une cachée dissimulée dans le bas
d'une étagère dans un sac un morceau de
bas relief en pierre regardez il ya deux
tigres un tigre ici le deuxième l'a et
un bouddha mais il est un peu cassé
cette pièce a besoin de 2000 en vain
nous sommes autorisés à prendre des
photos de la sculpture ainsi que d'une
tête de statue présentée elle aussi
comme une antiquité parler un peu du
prix
les contrebandiers nous demandent cinq
mille dollars pour la tête 8000 pour le
bas relief et c'est non négociable
comment avez vous ramener ces choses
j'ai des amis je leur donne de l'argent
et il s'en charge
ils vivent la nuit pour croire que ces
choses
oui exactement moi si tu me donner un
million de dollars
je n'irai pas ça peut être très
dangereux tu peux prendre 20 ans 15 ans
en prison
oui prison ferme les pièces que les
contrebandiers nous ont présentés sont l
authentique serait il donc si facile de
se procurer des antiquités bouddhistes
en afghanistan pour le savoir nous
sommes allés montrer les photos à
l'équipe d'archéologues de philippe
marquis le morceau de bas-reliefs pour
commencer dirait qu'un des éléments qui
me rend assez affirmatif c'est
exactement le fait qu' il y ait plus la
tête des bouddhas toit m'est donc si
ç'avait été un fou les types autres ont
ils se réveillent débrouiller pour
garder pour piquer une tête
ça c'est bon il n'y a pas de problème
mon avis là pour le coup c'est pas du
tout hein c'est pas un faux
dans une belle pièce on est sûr rouge
sur les lèvres qu'on ait ces traces pour
suggérer qu ici que les litiges soit
bleu tout ça c'est quand même sa musique
plutôt dans le sens d'un authentique
quoi les archéologues constate amer et
ne peuvent que déplorer le phénomène
le piège est une catastrophe pour noir
kellogg il est pour ce pays parce
qu'effectivement c'est son patrimoine
donc sa richesse c'est que ce qu'ils ont
hérité de leurs ancêtres et des ancêtres
de leurs ancêtres
que ce soient dispersées vendus à
l'encan morcelé pour être mieux vendus
c'est une catastrophe complète run c'est
le problème du pillage c'est que ça ne
peut pas être le fait uniquement de
d'individus isolés
c'est à dire qu'effectivement il ya des
gens qui peuvent faire des fouilles
clandestines sortir des objets mais
derrière ces objets il faut pouvoir les
vendre il faut pouvoir les faire sortir
du pays et donc du coup ça suppose une
organisation qui est pas forcément à la
portée du premier venu
face aux pilleurs et bientôt au
bulldozer chinois le musée de kaboul
semble être aujourd'hui le seul refuge
pour ses bouddhas
aujourd'hui il ne reste plus grand chose
des collections d'antan la plupart des
oeuvres ont été détruites sous le régime
des talibans mais les premières statues
en provenance de la mine de cuivre sont
en train d'arriver
250 sont désormais en lieu sûr et il en
resterait deux fois plus qu'en sol parmi
les plus belles de guerriers richement
décorés anne-laure se charge de la
réception
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas censé savoir
que c'est un guerrier a priori mais en
l'occurrence en fait on à la partie de
son armure et puis des protections pour
les épaules alors la tête est encore en
caisse privilégie détacher un peu plus
loin la tête a été retrouvé dans le
prolongement du corps face contre terre
ça tu as ça dépend des cas mais parfois
il reste il reste pas mal de terre de
fouilles à dégager c'est presque une
seconde découverte en fait
et puis bon c'est quand même fascinant
ça c'est sûr sont des objets qui n'ont
jamais été touché
j'ai un peu l'impression d'ouvrir un
cadeau et la tête du guerrier apparaît
telle qu'elle avait été façonnée il y à
des siècles
le deuxième guerrier n'a lui pas été
aussi bien conservé il a été retrouvé
cassé en plusieurs morceaux
on sait par exemple que ce fragment là
va se placer par ici bon une fois qu'on
sait où ses os ses fragments vont se
placer on va savoir quels sont les
manques et comment on va pouvoir faire
leur montage cette pièce là comme je
voulais montrer en fait il ya un énorme
vide dessous donc ça va poser des
problèmes structurels
et puis ici ça il ya des chances pour
que ce soit un fragment du buste en fait
on a justement l'autre guerrier qui
permet aussi de de faire quelques
correspondances donc fait ça ça
ressemble vraiment énormément à ce qu'on
a sur le buste de l'autre côté et là bas
il manque le talent la satisfaction il y
en a du début à la fin en fait c'est
vraiment c'est assez génial puis bon ça
pose des problèmes de restauration qui
sont sont pas simples mais pour le coup
très intéressant devant ces trésors une
sorte d'émotion fébrile le conservateur
du musée ne parvient plus à détacher son
regard de ce guerrier revenus du passé
nous sommes tellement heureux vous savez
quand ils ont apporté cette statue au
musée national
on l'a observé et ça a été un sacré choc
et parce qu'il est si rare c'est une
bonne preuve de l'histoire et de l'art
de l'afghanistan pour les générations
futures
les jeunes générations ça montre que nos
ancêtres étaient comme ça c'était des
artistes aiment en de merveilleux
artistes
sur le site des fouilles ce matin-là une
drôle de surprise attendait les
archéologues afghans une rencontre
totalement inattendue je les ai déjà vus
ce temple oui c'est vraiment très ancien
chapeau de paille appareil photo 5
chinois a poussé par la curiosité ont
quitté leur camp retranché
choc de culture tout sépare afghans et
chinois les uns ont un pays en ruine à
reconstruire le pays des autres
connaître une croissance enviables le
premier contact est difficile
[Musique]
la prochaine fois il faudra que l'on
vienne avec un traducteur c'est vrai on
n'arrive pas à se comprendre
ce monsieur blanc essaie aussi de nous
parler mais je ne comprends rien
[Musique]
cinq minutes de visite amicale et ils
repartent quand l'exploitation minière
commencera-t-elle ils n'ont rien dit les
archéologues espèrent toujours avoir le
temps de sauver l'essentiel pour
beaucoup de gens la question est de
savoir est ce que la playlist en a du
temps à perdre a travaillé sur
l'archéologie alors que vont les
urgences économiques sont sont multiples
bien entendu notre réponse elle est de
dire on peut pas comment dire ignorer la
rue et qu'on dira au détriment de
l'autre c'est à dire que développement
d'un pays bas et il doit tenir compte de
toutes les composantes de ce pays est la
composante culturelle et par la moindre
des composants
[Musique]
autour de cette mine de cuivre se joue
probablement une partie de l'avenir de
l'afghanistan
réussir à tirer le meilleur du
gigantesque chalenge économique et du
colossal défi culturel pourrait remettre
le pays sur les rails
[Musique]